[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du site du 7-8
société votre rendez vous hebdomadaire
pour débattre discuter et réfléchir sur
les grands enjeux qui touchent nos
vielles qui font l'actualité des
rassemblements interdits au québec des
réunions familiales autorisé jusqu'à 10
personnes en allemagne et des
célébrations possible dans la plus
grande prudence en france dans une
quinzaine de jours ce sera le réveillon
de noël la situation sanitaire ne
s'améliorant pas pour le moment la
question de fêtes de fin d'année dite
normale et sur de nombreuses lèvres on
en parle avec nos invités jean frédéric
bou adjoint de direction yvelines des
petits frères des pauvres bonsoir
bonsoir est la pige à membre du conseil
d'administration de l'union des
commerçants et artisans de la commune de
maurepas bonsoir bonsoir et daniel
duterte vous êtes la présidente de la
fédération des yvelines de l'union
nationale des retraités et des personnes
âgées
bonsoir bonsoir
alors demain soir jeudi 10 décembre à 18
heures le premier ministre jean castex
se donnera une nouvelle conférence de
presse sur les mesures contre la cohue
19 et hier soir marc de mardi 8 décembre
chez nos confrères de lci
olive et veyran annoncé ne pas revenir
sur l'absence de règles et sur le
maintien des recommandations c'est à
dire 6 à table pour noël mais souvent
les réunions familiales sont plus
nombreuses je voudrais commencer avec
vous est la pige à londres monde à table
c'est moins de préparation culinaire est
ce que les commerçants de bouche
maurepas dia sont inquiets de ce côté là
alors les commencements de bouche
maurepas siens sont pas vraiment inquiet
bon ils savent qu'ils vont travailler
par contre effectivement et remarque une
baisse du chiffre d'affaires notamment
duo commandes qui sont vraiment des
commandes beaucoup beaucoup moins grosse
à l'est par exemple les bûches de noël
vont le boulanger avait plutôt tendance
à vendre des gays des bûches pour des
personnes vont maintenant c'est des
bûches de trois personnes voire quatre
maximum donc sa dalle les commerçants dû
s'adapter aux commandes justement pour
réduire la taille
grosse inquiétude on est pas trop encore
comment ça va se passer avec le discours
du 15 décembre
donc en fait
les commerçants type boucherie ont
besoin de faire des commandes auprès de
leurs fournisseurs donc c'est vrai que
ça repose sa pose quelques petits soucis
d'organisation
daniel duterte depuis le mois de mars on
sait que les personnes âgées les
retraités font partie parfois des
personnes les plus fragiles
est ce qu'un renforcement des
restrictions écrin du côté de votre
union nationale des retraités des
personnes âgées
si vous voulez il est craint et bien
évidemment mais le problème c'est que
ils ont peur ils ont ils ont les
personnes âgées sont quand même un petit
peu paniqué et même quand on nous on a
bouffé savez entre les deux confinement
on a rouvert les salles pendant mon
mandat m droit avec 10 personnes et les
gens on avait du mal à voir dix
personnes et puis les enfants veulent
que les parents restent bien au chaud et
à la duke au vide
donc c'est très compliqué alors noël sur
la période des rassemblements on essaye
de les joindre par hé oui mais on pourra
pas faire de rassemblement on a tout
annulé toutes nos sorties on était en
faisait un cabaret en décembre faisait d
un repas festif et donc là on a tout
annulé donc qu'on va aller leurs portes
et un présent à chacun on va on va
s'arranger
le bureau elle est leur portée quand
même un petit quelque chose pour nous
sachant pense à eux quand même voilà
justement on vous disait vous allez
apporter des petites choses il ya des
villes qui organisent d'habitude des
bals des goûters ou encore des repas la
cohue 19 avec la coved 19 ces moments de
convivialité sont annulés mais pour
continuer à garder le contact avec leur
seigneur et donner un peu de sourire en
cette période les villes lens ou
maintiennent un colis gourmand c'est le
cas à elancourt on écoute la maire
adjointe déléguée à l'animation seniors
de la commune
[Musique]
on a donc des colis comme que nous
donnons enfin aux personnes de plus de
75 ans et puis il ya effectivement la
traditionnelle soirée journée dansante
où ils sont l'an dernier ils étaient
environ 1000 personnes
on le fait en deux fois en deux temps
bon cette année effectivement nous avons
changé notre optique parce que ben vu
les circonstances la crise sanitaire
on a vu que les personnes avaient envie
de recommencer à ce lien social et puis
effectivement moi quand je les croise
dans la rue on marque apple en bas côté
ce qu'on va reprendre les activités
on a voulu vraiment maintenir ce lien en
leur offrant un petit présent c'étaient
les colis gourmand au vert pour tous nos
seniors inscrits sur notre liste au
niveau du ccs puisque comment être
inscrit sur cette liste c'est une
démarche volontaire
[Musique]
au final bonne chose
il ya du foie gras il ya un confit il ya
des confiseries
il ya une bouteille de vin noël est
aussi un moment où la solitude peut être
exacerbée on peut avoir des proches
éloigne on peut être fâché avec certains
de nos proches
lutter contre l'isolément de nos aînés
c'est l'une des missions de
l'association des petits frères des
pauvres gens frédéric bou comment vous
allez accompagner ce public
eh bien ce sont les vols habituellement
qui organise des grands repas avec les
personnes âgées isolées qu'on accompagne
tout le long de l'année
mais cette année là vu que les bénévoles
invente des petites solutions des
petites choses et ils ont parfois été
obligé de changer de projet de
confinement confinement donc
d'habitude on prépare noël dès juin
juillet août va même parfois avant et là
donc les bénévoles sont obligées de
réorganiser à chaque fois de réduire les
repas etc donc à minima des personnes se
verront remettre soit un colis et on est
peut-être que certains accepteront de le
partager avec des personnes isolées
ça dépendra beaucoup de ce que la
personne âgée isolée a envie de faire ce
qu'elle peut avoir aussi peuvent des
bénévoles n'ont pas forcément envie
aussi de risques de contamination des
personnes qui les accompagnent le reste
de l'année mais mais des bénévoles les
équipes de bénévoles sur le terrain vont
inventer des petites choses préparer le
repas plutôt que d'apporter un colis ce
les préparer le repas la veille et il
apportait directement c'est plus
sympathique envers un colis ça peut être
rédiger des cartes postales donc on a
une école à londres qui a proposé de
nous envoyer des cartes postales de des
enfants et donc ses cartes là vont être
remises aux bénévoles qui le remettront
personnages âgées accompagnées de nos
équipes
ça peut être des gâteaux ça peut être
plein de petites attentions des fleurs
mais pour marquer le 24 et 25 ont fait
le noël 24 et 25 cl vraiment ces jours
là où la douleur de l'isolément ou de la
solitude et la plus la plus difficile
donc des bénévoles se mobilisent pour
seb 2 jours là ce qui veut pas dire
qu'il veut pas y avoir d attention à
très haut débit ou après le mois de
janvier ou en décembre mais c'est
vraiment ces deux jours là pour nous qui
sont essentiels eh bien je pourrai pour
leur dire bravo à tous ces bénévoles
parce que certains peuvent aussi avoir
peur de sortir on a des bénévoles
retraités des jeunes retraités des moins
jeunes retraités ils peuvent se sentir
aussi inquiets d'être contaminé en en
ayant des activités bénévoles et je
trouve qu'ils font preuve d'une d'une
imagination et data une bonne humeur
malgré tout c'est une si tu donnes
rganisation alors chaque semaine nous
interrogeons nos téléspectateurs sur le
thème de l'émission la question du jour
c'est allez vous renoncer à noël en
famille en raison de lakovic 19 et c'est
le nom qu'ils l'emportent à 62 5% et
certains ont même partagé ce que serait
leur noël alors pour le danois souliers
cela se fera dans le respect des gestes
barrières pour antonio nito
noël est le socle des valeurs de la
famille et certains comme w vont étaler
les fêtes pour ne pas dépasser les huit
convives
jean frédéric bau est ce que cela
permettra d'avoir peut-être moins de
personnes isolées de l'auteur perp ou
vous qu'on vous craignez au contraire
d'avoir plus de personnes a accompagné
plus de peine à apaiser
alors nous en fait on a des actions avec
des personnes qu'on accompagne
au quotidien donc c'est des personnes
qu'on connaît donc notre travail c'est
d'essayer de maintenir ce lien
ensuite ce qui est des partenaires ou
des uns ou des personnes âgées qui sont
isolés pendant cette période de noël
veulent qu'on les accompagne
après il faut qu'elle se fasse connaître
deux de nos actifs bénévoles pour que
rufisque ont fait crée du lien donc
logiquement toutes les personnes que
nous on accompagne auront un contact un
geste une visite le 24 25
l'éclair par les maintiendra
probablement pas ou alors sur des tout
petits groupes de trois avec les grandes
tables si on a eu en bien mais
heureusement que nous fais actuellement
même à six ou huit
c'est pas très prudent et on l'a entendu
il faut donc innover se renouveler la
pige à les commerçants de maurepas ils
ont l'habitude justement d'innover il
anime régulièrement les quartiers dans
lesquels ils sont installés ils ont même
créé en 2010 est un chèque un chéquier
avantage est ce que pour ce deuxième
confinement ils ont élaboré de nouvelles
idées ou est-ce qui souffre depuis
encore ce deuxième confinement à l'eau
en fait non
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas eu
d'animations particulières
posco vide pour l'instant maintenant oui
des commerçants sont obligés de se
réinventer
donc au niveau 2
l'union des commerçants donc il a été
mis en place un groupe un groupe les
bons plans des commerçants sur facebook
de façon à pouvoir parce que chaque
commerçant puisse mettre bas c'est
romain tillon s'est passé baisse et ses
bons plans proposés des nouveaux
services également
donc oui c'est une façon de se
réinventer
donc tous ensemble les commerçants se se
doivent de trouver des solutions pour
pour pour proposer des nouveaux services
innovants alors un client
le marché de noël de la commune va en
plus se tenir les 11 12 et 13 décembre
est ce que ça leur permet de souffler
aussi de rentrer un peu dans l'esprit de
noël qui nous semble un peu loin de
rentrer dans l'esprit de noël je pense
que les commerçants le sont déjà depuis
depuis plus depuis deux mois presque
décoration les décoration des vitrines
en pouvant sont la preuve
les ventes de jean pays au revoir
excusez moi mais les gens n'en retrouve
madame du tertre qui était en ligne par
téléphone avec notre régie jeu vous
permet de terminer madame pigeât et
madame dutertre après je viendrai
inverse vous d'accord
donc oui je disais effectivement la
magie de noël
on continue à la proposer au niveau de
la clientèle
parce que c'est important même si ça va
être un noël qui sera un petit peu
différent des autres années
il n'empêche qu'il est qu'il est
toujours là et donc il faut continuer à
travailler il faut continuer à proposer
du service au client et je remarque
aujourd'hui que les clients sont très
fidèles et continuent à venir à venir
dans le dans le petit commerce et
veulent faire travailler des commerces
de proximité pour continuer à interdire
le le coeur de nos centres villes
alors justement on disait tout à l'heure
les commerçants font des portions plus
petites il ya aussi une phrase qui a
fait réagir le 24 novembre dernier le
professeur rémy à salomon président de
la commission médicale d'établissement
de l'ap-hp avait déclaré sur le plateau
de france info on coupe la bûche de noël
en deux et papis et mamies mange dans la
cuisine et nous dans la salle à manger
il s'excusera par la suite sur twitter
mais daniel du tertre est ce qu'on n'a
pas trop tendance à mélanger toutes les
personnes âgées est aussi allé mettre un
peu de côté qu'en cette période ont
compté je ne pense pas je pense quand
même que les enfants enfin le maximum en
france plusieurs fois enfin aux deux
jours ça le soir ce sera le lendemain
soir on va essayer quand même de
respecter par mois je continue de voir
mes petits enfants
je mets un masque je fais le maximum je
ne mange pas la cuisine puis en bout de
table pour essayer de
mais bon il faut quand même les on
respectera quand même alors puisque vous
en êtes tous les enfants je vous
souhaitez un paroles de mon petit fils
mais pour le père noël
il demande pas de jouer il demande
simplement qui retire le coc vide on
pourrait refaire des cap et un bac et
hammami monsieur vous je vous ai vu vous
vouliez réagir j'allais dire que les
personnes âgées je parle de toutes les
personnes âgées je parle des personnes
âgées isolées elles sont déjà relégués
là depuis longtemps et parfois oubliées
dire qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
personnages et qui ne voit personne ou
quasiment personne on a évalué comme
enquête à 300000 personnes 310 personnes
âgées qui nous vaut quasiment jamais
personne n'a durant toute l'année
ainsi quasiment une mort sociale donc
ces personnes là elles sont pas attendus
qu'au vite pour ne voir personne et être
résistance et je pense aussi aux
personnes qui n'ont pas beaucoup de
visites en maison de retraite en ehpad
qui elles aussi sont invisibles du monde
de moderne donc n'oublions pas que en
dehors des crises unitaire on a aussi ce
public 1 qu'il faut rejoindre au
quotidien si le fait de croire l on
parle des personnes âgées isolées et qui
vont pas avoir beaucoup de visites parce
qu'on aime chez sanitaire mais avec sion
au jour le jour et depuis des années des
personnes âgées seules mais vivait
difficilement cette solitude je voulais
dit et je voulais aussi salué le fait
qu'une des
personnes âgées un nouvel outil
bénéficier dans les maisons de retraite
on n'est pas de l'application à des
bénévoles parce qu'ils ont un peu de mal
il est vrai qu'en ce moment
mettez un personnel mobilisé pour
bourgeois y est les personnes en maison
de retraite on les oublie aussi mais
c'est eux qui vont créer du lien et de
la fête le jour de noël
parce que ces personnes le personnel
voire plus attentifs y aura peut-être
des gestes attentif des personnels donc
ils ont du mal aussi en ce moment mais
il faut aussi penser à lui voilà l api
ja on est tous suspendus aux décisions
du gouvernement
c'est l'inquiétude qui prime où on
essaie d'être un petit peu optimiste
en cette période c'est quand même un peu
l'inquiétude ont été peints après
quelles seront les décisions qui seront
prises pour le mois de
janvier février il y aura-t-il encore
1re confinement il y aura un thème
encore des fermetures de commerces dits
non essentiels même si ce terme est un
petit peu est un petit peu dié je n'ai
pas terry peuvent - c'est tous les
commerces sont essentielles entre nous
donc oui une petite inquiétude
ne serait ce que pour l'organisation
également beaucoup de commerces y
compris des commerçants de bouche
attendent avec impatience le discours du
du case de façon à savoir
si noël sera bien possible à fêter
daniel duquenne jean-frédéric vous quel
est l'état d'esprit actuel on sent les
il ya un peu d'inquiétude du côté des
commerçants et surtout il faut patienter
c'est ce qui se ressent aussi du côté de
vos adhérents ou de vos bénéficiaires
madame duterde peut-être en premier eh
bien écoutez ce qui a été une bonne
chose c'est que au deuxième continent
ils ont laissé les marchés ont rouvert
les marchés tiens c'était vraiment parce
que là il ya de la convivialité et bien
souvent les personnes âgées bon y aller
facilement quand même des comme les
commerçants sont ravis et bien je suis
pas je suis pas sectaire là dessus un et
c'est très bien qu'ils aient ouvert que
là vraiment les gens ils peuvent parler
de la convivialité bien voyez c'est
vraiment ça je pense que ça peut ça fait
du lien ça fait vraiment du lien social
monsieur vous même ressentir du côté de
vos bénéficiaires vaches
moi je pensais que mon premier
confinement il s'était plutôt la peur
qui domine est je pense que ce qui
domine aujourd'hui c'est plutôt la
patience comment recréer le lien comment
maintenir comment penser aux vacances
puisqu'on accompagnent des personnes
âgées en vacances ou 6 il ya comment
refléter les anniversaires etc
donc il ya une forme d'impatience plus
que de peur même s'il faut être très
prudent
donc on freine parfois c'est une
bénévole en fait attention il ya quand
même la crise etc
je pense que si j'avoue ce petit réagir
juste de rajouter que effectivement pour
compléter ce que disait madame dutertre
le marché oui c'est un lien social les
commerces de proximité sont également
un lien social beaucoup de personnes
âgées sont seuls en besoin d'aller voir
les ces commerçants pour pour discuter
pour parler de leurs soucis etc
et c'est vraiment c'est vraiment le lien
social et oui c'est une bonne chose que
les commerces la ré ouvert y compris les
non essentiels merci à tous les trois
d'avoir accepté notre invitation on va
on va terminer sur ces man l'aura bien
compris il faudra patienter et c'est la
convivialité qui manquera peut-être pour
ce noël c'est la fin de ce sept huit
sociétés l'émission est à voir et à
revoir sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
et d'ici là prenez soin de vous
[Musique]